i want to jump into falcon and winter
soldier
um i got to see the first episode and oh
yeah i'm all
in on this um that's what i can you know
my quick review
um but talk a little bit of how long you
worked on that project
and what exactly you did for people that
are not sure or
unfamiliar uh it was a swift one
you know just because of the timing of
the production and everything involved
i mean i think in the room and uh
writing episodes it was you know less
about two months
you know um and they were a hectic two
months
and honestly it was my first um
experience
in a writer's room in that capacity and
uh between spelman and musso and castle
line
and uh everyone else whose names
whenever i'm interviewed i forget
because i'm an [ __ ] from time to time
i'm just tired man uh
it was a joy but it's tough because you
show up at nine o'clock you're there
till six
and then you go home and you write and
uh
one of the joys about working at uh
marvel has always been kevin feige
because um you know you bump into him in
the hallway he remembers your name
and when you turn in a script within 45
minutes in my experience he got back to
us
uh and i will say after i turned in my
into episode three and four when i
turned in episode three
he read it emailed me quick very
praised happy happy and then i got 15
pages of single
space notes and i was like oh [ __ ] i'm
fired
then you start reading the notes and
they were both macro
micro and minutia and it made it better
man
and suddenly you started delving in with
someone who's like look i totally get
the point of the spear
but let's find that stone and hone it
down even sharper and uh
i learned a lot and to malcolm's biggest
credit it was
a room where you look forward to being
there and that uh the best idea wins
even if it created work you wanted to
hear that idea
because come the end of it you wanted
the series to uh
be as good as you could make it when you
get those notes back the
15 pages is that coming from feige or
coming from like a big team of people
that have read it
it's it's it's that's not just feige no
i mean it's it's
it's the it's the uh you know
probably 12 to 15 people and all of
their notes are compiled
and by the way the cool thing about the
notes to
the assistant's credit uh there was
nothing in those notes that was
repetitive or conflictive
and if it was conflictive it would be
like okay these are conflicting notes
you're like oh thank god
you know um but you know i think they
referred to
the the the heads of marvel as the
parliament you know there's 15 of them
or whatever that
that uh meet at the beginning of the day
and the end of the day so it was their
notes you know
um but for the most part man uh you know
you loved finally getting a draft and
you're like
hey great job it's gonna go to
production a lot it's gonna change
like yep good luck man well
i think the the one thing that i think
every marvel fan
knows uh is that they create some
amazing stuff and that it's probably
this teamwork
that gets to that place where everyone
loves it
yeah yeah dude i mean everyone in that
room is already kind of a fan in a
certain capacities
even if you're you're younger and you
don't know the comic books or the video
games or anything else
uh cartoons you know the number of
people i talk to now
that are like their fav mcu is their
star wars you know and so
in that room you can you can bandy about
wouldn't it be cool if
and there's a small possibility that
happens and in falcon and winter soldier
it happens a couple of times and you're
like oh you know i love that one of the
things that um
i heard and maybe i'm wrong about this
is that
uh because i think when you guys were
writing and maybe you can
correct me if i'm wrong but you know
it's a tv show
it's taking place in the mcu and i'm
curious if you guys ever wrote
anything like say an action set piece
where you're like we can't afford that
let's do this
and then the the higher ups would come
in and say oh no write the biggest thing
you can think of
don't it was that i mean in the third
one there's a massive action sequence
and i wrote it and i was like yeah i
know
it's it's not gonna happen they came
back with no i love it can you make it a
little bit bigger i'm like
what you know because it's at that point
like
i said before like i like tent poles but
i also like those hallway sequences
and so uh marvel likes that too but if
there's too many hallways they're like
hey can we blow some [ __ ] up
yes we can um i would imagine
that getting to play with these
characters was amazing
just as a fan is there anything that you
read in the comics growing up or
anything you knew as a fan
that you wanted to make sure got into
these episodes and were you able
to make it happen yeah yeah
a couple of times very very minute you
know i can't really say what
um but when you think of uh you know
marvel's in the room in your breaking
story right zoe
it was the lead on that and um the
number of times
we'd say can we use this character or
allude to this character
or is there a character that would do
this that'd be kind of cool to flush out
the world
and a lot of times uh it won't work but
every now and then
it would be like guys i think that's
kind of working and suddenly
you know when you think of uh you know
the the the
the noir of it all to have someone just
say something in the background
where five people are gonna be like did
he just say what i thought he he
said and it just alludes to a larger
world even if the payoffs aren't in the
first season or even our seas
in our series the the the seeds have
been planted
now one of the things i took away from
the first episode
is and it obviously couldn't have been
planned uh the timing that the series
deals with mental health
and the fact that the first episode um
bucky is getting therapy
and um which is something that a lot of
i commend the series for doing this and
for treating it with respect
and the fact that he's really dealing
with something and you know there's a
lot of people in the world
talking about that right now mental
health and the importance of it can you
sort of talk about that aspect of the
series
and the you know not the weird timing
but the timing
ah you know honestly it comes down to
everything everyone in that room
and most writers i know it's like look
there's there's fantasy there's horror
there's these the temple of it all but
you still want something that's
grounded plus 15 and when you look at
the movies that we love there are always
those moments
where it harkens back to something that
someone in the writers room was dealing
with
and i think the other thing too is you
look at these characters and if you
actually applied them to the real world
you'd be like this guy will be drinking
nine crates of vodka a day
to deal with what he's dealing with
right and so we you know that the dot
that was
beaming the bottle the classic iron man
and some of those other ones
like we wanted to kind of do a nod to
those at the same time like
we love characters that are strong and
yet we love seeing the frailties in them
and them recognizing the frailties like
we do and seeking to adjust
and heal and i think that makes him
more of a hero and less of an anti-hero
because at a certain point in what we do
like dude i like annie heroes like the
like like everyone else but like
goddammit i just want a hero again
you know so it was a lot of those
elements and to your point on
some of the best tv it was a small uh
quiet uh kind of like soft and gentle
scene
with a little bit of con you know
conflict amidst the construct but you
kind of knew
that the subtext was something much
deeper and we'll see further
on down the road what it really was
about um and that's to to everyone's
credit
uh you know malcolm and dalen that first
one's awesome
when you are doing a series like this
how much is marvel
pulling you aside and saying okay so
this is what's going on in the bigger
universe
we got to tell you about this this and
this and how much is it sort of like
we're only going to tell you what you
need to know
yeah it's it's needed no man it's
completely needed now like even when we
were in
the offices in that was it 532 years ago
before covet
where we would be talking about um
story in the in the in the little lunch
room there
and you would have a guard like he's the
sweetest guy in the world
but it's just like he's a he's a guard
but sweet guy would be like hey guys
just
just please don't talk about your your
show outside the room
like done done but it was more of that
whole like
they know we have clues
we have things we can and cannot say um
but
outside of the select few like i'm as
surprised as the rest of us where
certain episodes of other seasons and
series go you know
was this a one and done thing with you
and marvel or are you gonna
are you working on it i got nothing in
the works with them right now
um but uh it was a joy and i do it again
in the heartbeat
and you know part of my little extro
interview in regards to
favorite characters it goes back to what
we're talking about at the beginning
i just want an actor or a an exact or a
producer or a director coming to me
going
derek this is my favorite guy and i can
go like great let's go make that
um because honestly left to my own
devices i'd want 12 million dollars an
ambush bug or something weird
you know completely what did you get any
cool schwag
for working on the series like did you
get to create a sweatshirt
or is there anything that they give you
for doing that i got a cap but i got a
giant head
so it fits my four-year-old um but no i
mean when you think about the schweig
you get for marvel
and that's why you get from studios like
uh i'm doing uh something with
uh you know oh i can't tell you that
but they sent me boxes of stuff and i
ended up just giving it to a friend who
knew as a fan
um you know and it's kind of it's kind
of a joy where you get something and it
says
you know one like let's say 73-300
you know so it's just it's rare you're
like that's awesome and then you call up
a cousin going because my cousin's name
is john wick
and i'll be like hey you want some cool
john which way